und das passiert mitten in der Größen
Energiekrise das Worst Case Szenario
hier sehen wir jetzt Hurrikan ihren wir
über Florida wütet die Bilder sind live
aus Florida vor wenigen Stunden trifft
er auf Land erwischt Florida mit voller
Wucht Stärke 4 von 5 als ob man bei
Tempo 250 den Kopf aus dem ICE hält und
dank Ihnen kennen wir all diese Daten wo
der Hurrikan mit welcher Wucht wie wütet
denn sie fliegen direkt in den Hurricane
ins Auge des Sturms sie sammeln Daten
zur windstillen Mitte des Wirbelsturms
sind sie gereist so und das hier sind
Bilder einer autobahnkamera sie sehen ja
fast nichts so doll peitscht der Wind
die Regenmassen hier von links nach
rechts es sind Überschwemmungen in den
Straßen umgestürzte Bäume abgeknickte
Straßenlaternen
der Hurrikan ist im Durchmesser
mittlerweile über 1.000 km groß und
drückt immer mehr Wasser ins Land das
Gegenteil in Tampa Bay hier sehen wir
kein Wasser ist herrscht Ebbe der Wind
hat das Wasser komplett aus der Bucht
rausgedrückt
und unser Bildreporter Herbert Bauer
Nebel ist für uns jetzt in Tampa Herbert
fleuder erwacht gerade in diesen Minuten
wie ist deine Bilanz der Nacht im
Zeichen von Wirbelsturm Ian
Tampa ist ist relativ glimpflich
ausgegangen diese Stadt ist mit einem
blauen Auge davon gekommen sie war ja
zunächst im Visier dieses Hurricanes
ganz schlimm allerdings ist die Lage im
Bereich Fort Myers Cape Coral dort kam
es besonders zu gefürchteten Sturmflut
es gibt viele Häuser die bis fast bis zu
den Dächern in den Wassermassen
versunken sind es war teilweise
lebensgefährlich Menschen flüchteten
sich in die Obergeschosse teilweise
sogar auf Dach es gibt hier
Rettungsaktionen die durchgeführt werden
hier werden praktisch Menschen von
Häuserdächern in Sicherheit gebracht
wirklich eine dramatische Lage
hinzukommt der Stromausfall 2 Millionen
Menschen hier in Florida sind jetzt
bereits betroffen sie sitzen im Dunkeln
in der Nacht die Nacht über natürlich
teilweise immer noch verängstigt über
diese unfassbare Naturgewalt die die
Hurricane hier entfacht hat wie gesagt
das waren Winde von ungefähr 250
Stundenkilometer der Sturm ist jetzt
weitergezogen eigentlich schwer über
Florida hinweg hat die ihr zu schwer
Niederschlägen und Regen Bögen küssen
geführt in Orlando Disney Disney World
der riesige verfügungspark ist
geschlossen und ihren ist jetzt hinaus
zieht jetzt bald hinaus wieder in den
Atlantik auf die andere Seite und
bedroht Amerika weiter ist das
Schlimmste überstanden wie geht es jetzt
weiter wir sehen auch gerade noch die
Livebilder zum einen dich in den Straßen
von Tampa zum anderen diese massiven
Wassermassen die hier teilweise auch vom
Wind einfach ins Land reingedrückt
werden was passiert da aktuell
vom Sturm selbst da ist muss man sagen
ist das Schlimmste überstanden hier an
der Westküste von Florida jetzt
natürlich gibt es enorme Regenmengen an
der Ostküste von Florida ungefähr
Daytona Beach hier top der Sturm gerade
es ist erstaunlich dass Ehen selbst als
er bereits weit im Landesinneren waren
immer noch die Stärke drei hatte also
ein signifikanter Hurricane das ist sehr
ungewöhnlich der normalerweise Schwächen
sich Hurricanes total schnell ab wenn
sie an Land gehen irgendwas so groß und
mächtig und wuchtig dass er einfach
diesen Schwung mitgenommen hat bei
seinem Zug quer über Florida jetzt
natürlich die ist das wichtigste die die
Aufräumungsarbeiten die und auch noch
nach wie vor Rettungsarbeiten man
versucht jetzt natürlich festzustellen
ob es noch vermisste Personen gibt ob
jemand noch gesucht werden muss das ist
jetzt das allerwichtigste aber klar ist
und klar wird den Menschen in Florida
wie auch in Amerika das ist
wahrscheinlich einer der teuersten und
gefährlichsten und schlimmsten
Wirbelstürme die Motorräder jemals
heimgesucht haben
Bildreporter Herbert Bauer Nebel live in
Tampa Florida herzlichen dank dir für
das Gespräch
und das hier ist er Hurrikan ihr in dem
Zeitraffer gefilmt von einer
verkehrskamera von einer Insel direkt
vor der Westküste Floridas ihren reist
alles mit sich mit Windgeschwindigkeiten
von über 200 km/h ganze Häuser nimmt er
mit drückt alles flussabwärts und hier
in Fort Myers in Florida drückt er Boote
und Yachten aneinander es sind wirklich
krasse Bilder erschreckende Bilder und
ihn hier wird ihren wahrscheinlich
schwimmen lassen hi Alarm in Florida in
Fort Myer ein Ort 30 Kilometer weit weg
vom Meer und doch plötzlich taucht ihr
diese Haiflosse auf direkt hinter dem
Zaun eines Vorgartens angespült von den
unfassbaren Wassermassen dieses
Wahnsinns Wirbelsturms mitten in der
Stadt plötzlich hier ein Hai und es gibt
auch fröhliche Bilder aus der Hurrikan
Hülle dank ihm hier dieser Mann wird im
Internet gerade gefeiert sein Name Mike
Ross sein Haus evakuiert steht drei
Meter unter Wasser und als aus dem
Fenster guckt entdeckt der eine kleine
Katze die sich aufs Vorderrad ohne
Chance gegen diese massiven Fluten aber
Mike zögert nicht wird ihr Schutzengel
kurz bevor ihr ihn auf Florida knallt
rettet er dann doch noch diese kleine
Katze hier und ist momentan der Star im
Internet man kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen wie gewaltig Hurricane ihren
hier gewütet hat wir haben einen vorher
nachher Vergleich für Sie auf kommen aus
einem Architekturbüro in Fort Myers ja
das ist wirklich wahnsinn das ist ein
Schwenk über die Umgebung man sieht wie
schnell die Überschwemmung tatsächlich
dazu nimmt die Sicht innerhalb von drei
Stunden also links dann eine Stunde
später dann drei Stunden später hier
scheint sogar ein ganzes Haus
angeschwemmt worden zu sein zumindest
ist es drei Stunden vor dem Hurrikan
noch nicht an dieser Stelle zu sehen ja
absolut beängstigende Bilder von dieser
brachialen Gewalt des Hurrikans
[Musik]